[Music]
spiral stairs were part of a strategy to
defend the towers of medieval castles
attackers had to climb single-file and
couldn't storm the castle all at once
and at the top of the stairs the
guardsmen could more easily maneuver
their swords giving them the upper hand
spiral stairs take people to the next
level without taking up a lot of space
they're compact and with their corkscrew
curvature
they can also be architectural features
production starts with the steel hubs
cut to the desired riser height a worker
files the sharp edges smooth and drills
a threaded hole which will be used to
fasten the treads in place
a computer-driven plasma system cuts
through a sheet of steel to produce the
pie shaped stair treads a worker
Nestle's the tread to the hub and clamps
him in a weld fixture
he also clams structural supports to the
base of the tread with everything in the
right configuration he welds the support
to the tread and the hub he'll make 12
of these hub and tread assemblies he
chips off the weld slag for cleaner
seams
a team slides the hub and tread
assemblies onto the center Pole and
rotates them to the correct position the
design geometry dictates the rotation
once rotated correctly the workers
fasten the hubs to the pole and add a
platform for the top step
a balusters spins in a lathe as tools
cut it to length and round the end to
the correct diameter the operator
measures the diameter
he inserts the rounded end in a die that
carves a thread into it a worker welds a
steel cup just above the threaded part
of the balusters this cup will support
the bow stir once it's been installed on
the thread he grinds the weld scale from
the cup he inserts the balusters through
holes in a metal spacer and the tread he
screws a nut onto the end to secure it
using rollers now another worker twists
long strips of metal into spiraling
handrails that match the rise of the
stairs he fits the rail to the top
balusters and clamps it in place he then
welds the balusters to the rail
he adds more railing until it spirals
all the way down to the first step the
team secures it to the platform the
spiral staircases metal structure is now
complete it's ready for the wooden
accents a worker applies glue two pieces
of red oak he'll use two of them to make
one Starck red he clamped to tread sets
in a fixture while the glue sets inserts
a shim and tightens the clamp to apply
downward pressure once the glue has
cured a planer shapes the tread
perfectly flat and to the desired
thickness after refining the profile a
worker rounds the edge of the stair
tread using a router after gluing strips
of wood together to create a curved
grayling he sands the excess adhesive
and with a file removes more of the glue
he turns the railing over and carves a
groove in the wood this will enable the
railing to be installed over the metal
rail support he adds some detailing
along the edge
a team then fits the wooden railing to
the metal support structure all of the
rail sections fit together perfectly
after the pre fit they removed the
railing and sculpt the edges to be
rounder the rounded edges complement the
overall spiral design a worker pre fits
the wooden treads to the metal structure
and then disassembles the entire spiral
staircase for painting and staining the
spiral stairs are then ready for
reassembly in the building they were
designed for they'll definitely add a
certain twist to the interior design